what do you make of the fact you
mentioned rise and fall the third reich
i just have you read that you've read it
twice and you read it twice yes okay
cause no one even knows what it what it
is yeah and i'm like i'm like wait i
thought this was like a super popping
book
super puff i i'm
i'm not like that i'm not that far in it
but it is it's so interesting yeah uh
it's written by a person that was there
which is uh very important to kind of
you know you start being like how could
this possibly happen and then when you
read rise and fall of the third reich
it's like
people tried really hard for this to not
happen
people tried they almost reinstated a
monarchy at one point to try to stop
this from happening like they almost
like
like abandoned democracy to try to get
this to not happen at least the way it
makes me feel is that there's a bunch of
small
moments on which history can turn yes
like small meetings
yes human interactions and it that's
both terrifying and inspiring because
it's like
um
even just attempts at assassinating
hitler like time and time again failed
and they were so close valkyrie mm-hmm
such a good and then there's also
also the role of
that's a really heavy burden which is
that from a geopolitical perspective the
role of leaders to see evil before it
truly becomes evil to anticipate it and
to stand up to evil
because evil is actually pretty rare in
this world at a scale that hitler was we
tend to you know in the modern discourse
kind of call people evil too quickly if
you
look at ancient history
like there was a ton of hitler's i i
actually think it's more the norm
than
like again going back to like my sort of
intelligent design theory i think one of
the things we've been successfully doing
in our slow move from survival of the
fittest to intelligent design is we've
kind of been eradicating
like if you look at like ancient assyria
and stuff like
that [ __ ] was like brutal and just like
the heads on the like like brutal like
like genghis khan just like genocide
after genocide after genocide was like
throwing plague bodies over the walls
and decimating whole cities or like like
the muslim conquests of like damascus
and [ __ ] just like people cities used to
get leveled
all the [ __ ] time okay
get into the bronze age collapse it's
basically there was like almost like
roman level like
society like there was like all over the
world like global trade like everything
was awesome through a mix of i think a
bit of climate change and then the
development of iron because basically
bronze could only come from this uh the
way to make bronze like everything had
to be funneled through this one iranian
um mine and so it's like there was just
this one supply chain and this is one of
the things that makes me worried about
supply chains and why i think we need to
be so thoughtful about
i think our biggest issue with society
right now
like the thing that is most likely to go
wrong is probably supply chain collapse
you know because war climate change
whatever like anything that causes
supply chain collapse our population is
too big to handle that and like the
thing that seems to cause dark ages is
mass supply chain collapse but
the bronze age collapse happened um
like
uh it was sort of like this
ancient collapse that happened where
like literally like um
ancient egypt all these cities
everything just got like decimated
destroyed abandoned cities like hundreds
of them there was like a flourishing
society like we were almost coming to
modernity and everything got leveled and
they had this many dark ages but it was
just like there's so little writing or
recording from that time that like there
isn't a lot of information about the
bronze age collapse but it was basically
equivalent to like medieval the medieval
dark ages but it just happened
i don't know the years but like
thousands of years
earlier and then
um we sort of like recovered from the
bronze age collapse
empire re-emerged writing and trade and
everything re-emerged
um you know and then we of course had
the more contemporary dark ages um and
then over time we've designed mechanism
to lessen and lessen the capability for
the destructive
uh there's more centers to emerge
there's more recording about the the
more contemporary dark ages so i think
we have like a better understanding of
how to avoid it but i still think we're
at high risk for it i think that's one
of the big the big risks right so the
natural state of being for humans is for
there to be a lot of hitler's we just
gotten really good
at making it
hard for them to emerge we've gotten
better at collaboration yes and
resisting the power
like authoritarians to come to power
we're trying to go country by country
like we're moving past this we're kind
of like slowly incrementally like moving
like moving towards like
not
scary old-school
war
stuff and i think seeing it happen in
some of the countries that at least
nominally are like
supposed to have moved past that that's
scary because it reminds us that it can
happen
like in in in the places that have made
like moved supposedly as hopefully moved
past that and possibly at a civilization
level like you said supply chain
collapse might make people resource
constrained
might
make people desperate
angry hateful violent
and drag us right back in i mean supply
chain collapse is how like the ultimate
thing that caused the middle ages was
supply chain collapse it's like people
because people were reliant on a certain
level of technology like people like you
look at like britain like they had glass
like people had um aqueducts people had
like
indoor heating and cooling and like
running water and like
buy food
from all over the world and trade in
markets like people didn't know how to
hunt and forage and gather and so we're
in a similar situation we are not
educated enough to survive without
technology so if we have a supply chain
collapse that like limits our
access to technology there will be like
massive starvation and violence and and
displacement and war like like
you know
it's also it like yeah in my opinion
it's like the primary marker of of
dark
like what a dark ages well technology is
kind of enabling us to be more resilient
uh in terms of supply chain in terms of
to all the different catastrophic
catastrophic events that happened to us
although the pandemic has kind of
challenged our preparedness for um the
catastrophic
you